it was in this room when i was told that
the scanner churned that i had
tumors up and down my body uh all over
here
it was horrendous um it was a it was a
physical reaction
it literally you know you hear about
people talking about you feel like
you've been hit
i literally did that i remember feeling
remember feeling it i remember feeling
it physically
hi i'm nicola mendelson and i'm the vice
president for facebook in europe the
middle east and africa
my first ever job uh was probably as a
waitress
my parents have a catering business
and so from a very young age i used to
work for them at the weekends
so how did you go from working as a
waitress to getting into tech well there
was a very long journey from being a
waitress to working in tech which
basically took me through the world of
advertising an industry where i worked
for over 20 years
and then ultimately into facebook where
i joined about seven years ago
when i got the job at facebook it in
many ways it was very different but
there was also a lot of similarities
obviously the difference was it's a tech
company
it's at a big america it wasn't a big
american company then
it was much smaller than it is today but
at the heart of it there were so many of
the things that i'd learned in the world
of advertising that still rang true
the relationships that you have with
people the the whole advertising
business is also the business of
facebook as well that's how it makes its
money so so many of the relationships
and the connections
that i've built over the previous 20
years were certainly important
as i as i took on the role so what does
an average day at facebook look like
a typical day might be that i would meet
with small business owners
uh that use our platforms i might meet
with community
uh admins the people that are running
the groups on our platforms and they're
so wide and varied
i would meet with advertisers i would
meet with politicians i would meet with
our teams so there really is no such
thing
as a typical day and that's probably why
i love my job so much
what else do you love about your job i
feel very blessed to have
the job that i do because at the heart
of what i do is about people
it's about bringing people together
whether it's in the online world or
increasingly people use our platforms to
come together
in the real world as well and to see
you know the things that we were able to
help people to do and throughout the
pandemic whether it's the local
community groups
i'm in a few of them in this area where
total strangers came together to help
one another at a time when they needed
it
the very most and to think that that
happened as a result of
in some small part through the work that
i do every day
well that's definitely a good reason to
get out of bed
as a really prominent female leader in
quite a male dominated industry
do you see yourself as a role model i
don't think it's about uh the titles
that you have but i think it's
about what you can do in the position
that you're in
to be able to help the next generation
of women coming through and so through
my whole career
it's been really important to me that
that i've been able to
help other women whether it's through
advice whether it's through mentoring
whether it's through programs
and yes whether it's through people
seeing me and seeing well if she can do
it
a girl from manchester then maybe i can
do something like that too
i think over soon to be 30 years
working i definitely have seen a change
in the attitudes of
people leading organizations and a
greater consciousness and even
say momentum around wanting to address
the issues that
stop women reaching the top that said
we're nowhere near
seeing the representation that we want
of women in senior leadership
in in any industry organization
you know we still when a woman becomes a
ceo anywhere in the world it's still
like a rare celestial event
so there's been an increasing number of
documentaries such as the social dilemma
that have accused facebook of being a
villain do you think that's fair
i think it's very important that we do
take the time to have
considered conversations about social
media
the impacts that it has both good and
bad i think there's
a misconception around the fact that
facebook wants bad things on its
platforms or facebook makes money
uh from bad things on its platform it
doesn't
we we don't want that content on our
platform and
you can see that we don't want that by
looking actually at how much money we've
invested in this area
the majority of people that are coming
onto our platforms are doing so because
they're having a good experience they're
coming on because
they're connecting with their friends
their family brands entertainment
football teams the things that they care
about
and that's not to say that there isn't
some bad things on our there are
and when we find them and when we see
them we get it off and we take it down
i was diagnosed with follicular lymphoma
which is an incurable cancer
in 2016. getting a diagnosis
like that was um it was a shock
i wasn't ill um completely through me
i was living a very busy active for life
flying all over the world
managing you know the family for
children
um and it abso absolutely threw me
but when you do have a moment i think
everyone has a moment where you know
that
the world that you'd been living up till
that point was going to be very
different to
the world that um was going to come
thereafter and it was actually in this
room
um especially in this room that i i got
the news uh that um
i'd had a scan and honestly i hadn't
thought anything of it
and i it was it was in this room when i
was told that the scanner churned that i
had
tumors up and down my body uh all over
here it was horrendous
um it was a it was a physical reaction
it literally you know you hear about
people talking about you feel like
you've been hit
i literally did that i remember feeling
um
remember feeling it i remember feeling
it physically
[Music]
the first thing that anybody that gets
diagnosed with any type of illness wants
to know is how long have i got
the stats say well first off i should be
65 and a man
at getting diagnosed i'm not i was 45
when i was diagnosed
um it says typically that you
on average could could live up to 20
years
some people longer some less but in the
20 years
you'll probably need between six and
eight treatments
and currently as of 2020 there's no cure
for this cancer
when people get uh a life-changing
diagnosis
it's pretty common that they do some
drastically different things in their
lives
you know you hear about the people that
suddenly have to go and climb a mountain
or
maybe get divorced or change jobs or
move country or whatever
i didn't do any of those things and and
i didn't do any of those things because
actually i feel that
i've always really spent a lot of time
thinking about where i am what i want to
do what matters to me and that's my
family
family first and foremost is the thing
that i've always cared
and always been my north star about
making sure that my family were
happy safe in a good way connected
when it came to work i've always been a
very open person
people that work with me will will speak
about that that i tell it as it is i
don't hide things i
i share but there is still a taboo um in
the workplace around
working and having a disease and
certainly having an incurable cancer i
think that's another area that i think
employers need to think about
whether they're creating an environment
that people can bring their full selves
to work
the good and the bad so how are you
feeling today
i am grateful that i am at this point
well i've had treatment um two years ago
which went well put me into a type of
remission where it said that i have no
minimal disease but it means i still
have it somewhere but we
we don't know when it's going to come
back up but as of today i'm well
the more time that i spent understanding
follicular lymphoma
the kind of the landscape the the
doctors involved
the more i realized that it was this was
a question of money and focus and if
there was more money and more focus put
into follicular lymphoma and talking to
the scientists talking to the top
researchers they all believe that this
is a cancer that could and should be
cured
and so that's the reason that i set up
the follicular lymphoma foundation
literally to find a cure and to take all
the learnings that i've had from
business from working in tech
to be agile to be a disrupter and to
find ways to come together alongside
with the group living with follicular
lymphoma on on facebook that now has
over
7 000 members in it it's the largest
gathering
of people with follicular lymphoma that
has ever existed and to come together
to raise the money to raise the
awareness
and so that hopefully this is a charity
that will not be in business very long
because we will have found that cure for
the hundreds of thousands of people
that are living with this cancer all
over the world
we're going to find a cure
at that point in my life like there's
there's no look there's not an easy way
for my man to have
abounded into my room and told me but
she just opened my door on a wednesday
morning
and said stephen your dad's dead he's
hung himself the first thing i did was
i remember punching the wall so angry
got up
walked to one of my friends built spliff
tried to make sense of it and i went for
a whole spectrum
of emotions